we are learning more now about the reality
that in the craziness of last week, Iran shot
down a passenger airplane killing everybody
on board.
This was a Boeing seven 39 seven
leaving Iran or Kia, a Ukrainian airline.
The evidence was growing and growing even
though Iranian, Iranian officials were denying
it, it became undeniable and over the weekend,
the officials in Iran for the first time admitted
that yes, they shot down a Ukrainian jet airplane
killing the hundred and 76 people that were
on the plane.
This does a few things aside from being an
unspeakable tragedy, including seriously hurting
the credibility of those same Iranian officials
who were insisting day after day last week,
that they had nothing to do with it.
When it was increasingly clear that they did
numerous questions about the airplane being
shot down.
One, why wasn't the Ron's airport closed in
airport airspace shut down during last week's
hostilities and the missile launches.
We don't have an answer there.
Oh, the associated press reports that general
Amir Ali had Geeza day.
The, uh, head of the guards, the Uranian guards
aerospace division, says his unit accept full
responsibility for the shoot down.
There was an address broadcast by state television
where he said when he learned the plane had
been taken down.
Quote, I wished I was dead.
He said that the airlines pilot and crew did
nothing wrong, that an officer made the bad
decision to open fire on the plane after mistaking
it for a cruise missile.
The Iranian Supreme leader, the Ayatollah,
expressed his deep sympathy to the families
of the victims said that the armed forces
should quote, pursue probable shortcomings
and guilt in the painful incident.
But the Uranian people are furious as they
should be.
Very quickly, protests against the establishment
Islamic theocracy of Iran have broken out
into Iran.
Of course, it was not just the radians who
died on that plane.
It's not any better or worse depending on
who dies.
But it was 82 Iranians, 57 Canadians, 11 Ukrainians,
and many others.
A Canadian prime minister, Justin Trudeau,
has been very involved in publicly speaking
about this.
And so many Canadians were on that plane.
Now there's a conversation happening about,
is this partially Donald Trump's fault?
And the reasoning is, well, Iran shot down
the plane while they were retaliating to the
United States, his assassination of Kaseem
Solemani.
So if Trump hadn't assassinated Soleimani,
Iran wouldn't have been firing missiles, and
all of these people would now be alive, you
know, in a strict, narrow scope that that
is technically true.
In other words, what caused Iran to be firing
the missiles was that Trump ordered Solemani
killed.
And you can argue that Iran retaliating was
less optional than Trump deciding to go and
assassinate Kaseem Soleimani in geopolitics.
This is a pretty dubious way of thinking about
things.
Trump can then say, well, the only reason
we killed Kaseem Solemani was because Obama,
instead of going after Soleimani signed a
terrible Iran nuclear deal, terrible according
to Trump, by the way.
And then we would say, no, no, no, that didn't
force you to assassinate Soleimani.
And Trump is can say, well, Iran didn't have
to respond with the missiles that they did,
or they should have been more competent.
They should have better trained the people
that were using the missiles, they should
have fired them at different locations from
different locations.
They should have cleared the airspace.
So for me, this is not so much about, uh,
trying to figure out what degree of blame
does Trump have for the shooting down of the
plane.
Again, you could say, well, what about the
Iranian revolution that took place in the
late 1970s that really caused everything that
happened in the last 40 years that led to
Trump even wanting to assassinate Sola money?
It's not all the same, right?
The Iranian revolution as a general cause
of today's status quo is not the same as Trump
personally saying let's kill Soleimani, which
leads to Iran firing these missiles that take
down a jet aircraft.
But the point is this type of accusation is
rarely useful in figuring out what needs to
happen next.
It's used mostly to score political points
for one side or for the other.
If everything had been the same, but Iranian
forces were better trained at distinguishing
a passenger plane from something else, this
wouldn't have happened.
Not to mention that this regime has been lying
about what happened as well.
The head of Ron's aviation organization, uh,
said that the plane definitely wasn't hit
by a missile just days ago and of course it
was, and they continued to lie until they
could lie no more.
So Trump gets plenty of blame for many things
he's done here.
The assassination ripping up the Iran nuclear
deal for no reason without Iran having violated
it, but the, to make the focus of the plane
being shot down as tragic and unnecessary
as it was to say that that was because of
Trump's decisions specifically is at minimum
unproductive.
I don't think it's the place where we should
be focusing our energy and now we have protests
any run and we will see what comes of them.
That is where our energy should be focused
and the fact that Iranians who are known to
be increasingly progressive as a population
fighting back publicly, publicly protesting
this Islamic theocracy that is in place in
Iran, that is what we should be focusing on.